So you got to bottom out first to the point and close some sort of like
addiction that when you come back to do the character again,
you don't really quite look like you anymore. And you're older.
You've got to add that sad element to it. Yeah. Well,
it's kind of like that now, because with Eno now at, towards the end,
he was just, he wouldn't shave anymore.
He would just kind of half-ass it with the wig on and it kind of looked,
he wouldn't mention how funny it looked. Yeah.
Cause he used to be real seriously.
I used to shave when you do a character is like a guy with a puppet where you
start hate in the puppet. You start hating the wig. After a while, you know,
I don't live in some Twilight zone and then wig and starts
talking to you. You ain't nothing without me,
nobody buys it. [inaudible]
let me be honest. Yeah. I didn't want you. Yeah,
you were nothing without me. Yeah. It's kind of a little, I never got that.
I know Pete comics would always ask me and they'd say, Hey,
are you sick of doing it? I was like, no, it's so fun. You know? I think if it,
if an question, are you sick of what's selling tickets? Oh,
well people do that all the time. Yeah. We'll do that. Me as a Patriots fan.
You gotta be secret only Superbowls. Yeah. No, they're great. Yeah.
It's going to end one day. I want to enjoy all of them. Yeah. Yeah. No,
I didn't. I didn't, uh, I didn't resent it or hate it for one.
It was so much fun. It was such a fun show doing it live.
Cause women would go crazy. They would go.
And it's fun to be in that character and just say wild.
I would say the funniest thing was like making straight guys uncomfortable in
the audience. I was sucked out. Look at him. Holly said,
are you a cop or a firefighter? I didn't know what a hero was.
And then just watching them kind of score him. Yeah. You stupid, man. You know,
just kind of try to get away. Yo man,
wild boy with their girls and their girls were loving it. And I,
so it was just fun to with people like that. That's the best of the best.
The best is the guy. That level of fun. There's nothing worse than it.
Wasn't a better, I'm sorry. The tickets were never dying down.
Now they start dying. Even in New York,
they start dying because you did somebody show kind of publicity.
You don't need that's right. And it was still don't go good. No instinct.
This thing that's working. I'm not doing it anymore.
And then you're going to hear the tickets book. man. Nah, caramel
people. Didn't like it. Everyone was offended. Yeah.
I started to like beat a woman with the wig. It's not coming back.
The wig took me, took over who I was. Yeah, it was all right.
Well we're not going to talk you back into your golden pony here. No. Yeah.
It's like, I think, you know, well just put it into the hyenas done.
I got a movie idea. Yeah.
You get sick of trying to talk him back into the dream. Okay.
Some chick breaks up with you. Something happens to you.
You come home and you're mad and for whatever reason you see the wig and then
you start doing it and then you start making all the money.
And then one day he runs into like Chris, what the is great. Yeah.
And then I don't, I can never get a movie pass the stupid second act.
Was that the first 10 pages? I don't know what it is then be like in it.
And you're like the, um, like the mic, the manager who's telling him, take,
take the wig. You do it. Like if he's not going to do it and I have this deep,
dark secret and you never know what it is.
And you find out later that I used to at the same thing happen to me.
And I started wearing a wig cause I lost my hair. And then you're just like,
you got one more in you. And I say, yeah. And then we go, we take him down.
And then the end I opened for you with my wig and then love it. Yeah.
We'll call it a wig. And he's in comedy jam. Comedy jails. Yeah.
We'll call it. Third act is the hardest to land one dream, two wigs.
What do we call this? A tough wigs. Um,
you set it up for the trilogy. Yeah. First wigs. It's almost like a,
for the hustler. It's like the hustler. And then, um, what was the,
what was the follow-up movie with? Um, other money?
It's almost like cuddle money. Yeah. A little bit good name.
Polar money is one of the most underrated Scorsese movies of all time.
I love color money. I didn't even know he did that one. Yeah.
A lot of people don't I love that. Rack them up for Mr. Fast. Eddie.
That's what it is. Yeah.
Now Bill's got a special outright now on Netflix called fast.
Billy it's called fast. Billy it's called Billy Boston.
It's called he's a New York comic. No, it's a, it's called a paper tiger.
I watched it. It's another band. Another band gets always a 10. Yeah.
So a lot of you prepare you guys. Well,
he did not take much. I, you know, I'm working for always,
always attend, unbelievably inspiring,
inspiring lists lists. I got the movie,
but I probably can't say it. What for the wig movie? Say it.
I got the name for it. Can I just say it? Say it, say it. There you go.
Give me just the character. It's my friend,
Pat Rooney. He hasn't been to the city. He's he's got I apologize.
I just said it. It's [inaudible] the character piece.
The chain was out now. It's back in. I apologize. I love paper tiger.
He's a guy he's from Ridgewood, Queens.
You shouldn't have sent paper tag without the yard. Although I say paper tiger.
Cause the change packet. I right here. It's paper tight,
but here it's paper tiger. Yeah. Great, great, great skit. Yeah.